the media have been hammering president
Trump making scurrilous charges that his
draconian immigration policies are
separating families and losing track of
illegal immigrant children the Trump
administration is threatening to
separate more parents and kids at the
border screaming and crying please don't
let me be taken away
they are traumatized who called about
7600 of those children and they couldn't
find 1500 of them
Donald Trump really is obsessed with
perhaps the most sick part of the entire
policy separating families from each
other
predictably the New York Times also
weighed in with a piece titled did the
Trump administration separate immigrant
children from parents and lose them
well as you will see this is not
reporting it's called trying to create a
narrative regardless of the actual facts
to manipulate readers emotions and
ultimately force a change in policy now
never one to forego a ride on the
bandwagon CNN's hadass Gould tweeted
this a picture of immigrant children and
what appeared to be cages with the
caption first photos of separated
migrant children at holding facility
well the inference of course being that
Trump himself was consigning innocent
children ripped from their mothers arms
into wired cages well the same picture
was shared by former Obama officials
like Jon Favreau and the usual Trump
hating activists such as women's March
board member Linda Sarsour but there's
only one problem with this photo
it's from 2014 you know when the saintly
Barack Obama and the compassionate ones
were all in charge at the time the
left-wing media did not consider
detaining illegals worth covering but
now the Trump is trying to enforce our
immigration laws he's suddenly just a
heartless thug Gould had to retract her
tweet but she didn't apologize writing
deleted previous tweet because gave the
impression of recent photos there from
2014 well
hadass it gave the impression
because you wrote that they were first
photos of migrant kids and detention
usually was one does it label something
first photos when they're four years old
well we're still waiting for the New
York Times to apologize for it's
outrageous headline it turns out that
The Times could have answered their own
question by reading further down in
their own piece did the Trump
administration separate immigrant
children from parents and lose them well
no they clearly didn't because The Times
writes that those children had arrived
alone at the southwest border without
their parents so I have a question how
can you separate illegal alien children
from their parents when the parents sent
them here alone well there is a glaring
loophole in the immigration law that
forbids border patrol from immediately
deporting unaccompanied minors from
Central America non contiguous countries
the illegals know this so they abuse the
system and I would argue endanger their
children in the process so what happens
when an unaccompanied illegal miner here
but remember he or she could be sixteen
seventeen or one day from his or her
18th birthday by the way
crosses the border illegally well the
United States then throws them into what
is essentially a foster care program
according to Steve Wagner and HHS
official the 10,000 children and teens
in custody cost the taxpayers over 1
billion dollars annually others are you
know sent to sponsors so what happens is
the government finds the kids sponsors
or family members in the United States
whom they can go to live with as their
case proceeds or better put as it drags
on for years
well of course few show up for their
deportation or immigration hearings so
as they charge at the Trump
administration lost 1475 immigrant kids
they didn't lose anybody
when HHS tried to check up on these kids
with their sponsors at times remember
illegal immigrant families themselves
caring for the children for
hundred and seventy-five failed to take
the calls or even respond to the
government at all
so the immigrant kids aren't lost their
sponsors just haven't connected with the
HHS or made themselves available but if
the media they want to misconstrue that
is losing a kid well okay let's do that
for a moment as to hypothetically let's
just say that that's correct well Obama
lost nearly three times the number of
kids the New York Times reporting a 2016
Inspector General report showed that the
federal government was able to reach
only eighty four percent of children it
had placed leaving 4159 unaccounted for
well correct me if I'm wrong I don't
remember any media lashing out at Obama
for losing kids or separating them from
their families in fact Obama and his
homeland security secretary tried to at
a few times tried to adopt a hard line
on the unaccompanied minors when there
was a huge rush at the border as you
recall back in 2014 our direct message
to the families in Central America do
not send your children to the borders if
they do make it they'll get sent back
our message to those who are coming here
illegally to those who are contemplating
coming here illegally into South Texas
is we will send you back one problem
they couldn't be sent home they couldn't
be deported because of the insane
immigration laws we currently have in
place by the way which is why Trump is
right the law has to change Congress
must act not only to end this
unaccompanied minor loophole but the
catch and release program as well as
chain migration asylum fraud all of it
so if you want to know why this anti
Trump media narrative is being advanced
at this time why it's because Trump is
close to making good on his promise to
transform our immigration laws for the
better even the left realizes this issue
is a winner for Republicans
Tom Friedman who is a favorite of the
global elite so you know obviously New
York Times bestselling author even he
this morning was recognizing this issue
as a vulnerability for Democrats I think
there are several things that are true
that Democrats have to wrestle with we
cannot take every immigrant in a world
that is splitting between the world of
order and disorder Wow
well now is not the time to go wobbly on
immigration or embrace some type of
blanket amnesty there is one point that
the left and the right should be able to
agree on especially given the recent
media indignation we all want children
to be together unified with their
parents so let's make that happen in the
country of their origin it is immoral to
allow laws on the books that incentivize
people to send their children alone into
a foreign country or to frankly make a
dangerous trick with their parents and
until those laws change immigrant
children will continue to be separated
from their parents no matter what the
President does now and that's the angle